اغنى اغنياء العالم فمع الخسائر التي
تتعرض لها الاسهم التقنيه ستطاع رجل اعمال
فرنسي برنار اخنوط تربع على عرش اغنى رجل
بالعالم بثروه بلغت 171 مليار دولار في
المقابل تراجع ثروه توماس الى 164 مليار
دولار
اغنوه رئيس مجلس اداره مجموعه البي ام اتش
ويمتلك وعائلته 48% من اسهم مجموعه
الرائده في مجال السلعه الفاخره بالعالم
والتي تملك 75 علامه تجاريه مختلفه
واشهرهم على الاطراف
لديهم اكثر من 5000 500 متجر حول العالم
سجلت قيمتها السوقيه
8388 مليار دولار وبلغت مبيعاتها في سنه
20 21 الى 68 مليار دولار
[موسيقى]
هذا القطار
الاقتصاديه
راينا ملك التقنيه الى الماسك يفقد مركزك
اغنى رجل في العالم لصالح ملك العلامات
الفاخره الفرنسي صاحب ايامك
هذا العام بنلاحظ انهم ماسك والفرق بين
شخصيتين الى الماسك كثير همم ظاهر للعالم
كثير بيحكي كتير بياثر حتى على يعني مشاعر
المستثمرين ان كان عم نحكي على شركه
بيتاثر بالنظر المستقبل
تراجع اسومه ب 16% من البدايه العام اكثر
من 43% بالوقت اللي عم بشوف قطاع يمكن
اللاكجري او همم
بتاع الامور يعني يمكن عم نحكي عن الساعات
ممكن نحكي حتى عن السيارات الفاخره
المجوهرات
اللي بعد كان عم يرتفع عم نشوف الاسهم
كمان مرتفع في هذا القطاع
جديده
كيف يعني تغير الثقافه المستهلكه اليوم او
انها تطورت وصارت بس ميال القطعه الفاخره
نحن نمر في زمن اصلا فيه ازمات اقتصاديه
تضخم ورفع سعر الفائده وتدهور عملات مشان
هيك بدنا نشوف المستهلك اللي يمكن كل ساعه
عم يستهدفه اذا عم نحكي انا مثلا عن تسله
ان كان حتى همم خلال فتره قافل وهسيول
العاليه بالاسماء خلت العديد من اسهم
التكنولوجيا ترتفع اساس ان احنا كنا
قاعدين بالبيوتنا كنا بنحاجه
تكنولوجيا لازم تتطور يمكن نحكي على
التواصل عن بعد عن كل شيء بتعلق بقطع
التكنولوجيا بالوقت الحالي مع السيول
المرتفعه مع ارتفاع الدولار في وجه
العملات الاخرى اذا بدنا نحكي اليورو اذا
ما نحكي عن الباونت خلت كل يمكن هالطبقه
بنعتبر
اعلى من المتوسطه والغنيه تكون عم تتوجه
اكثر لتكون عم تشتري هذه الامور اولا
سعرها باليورو او بالباوند كان عم يتراجع
ثاني شيء كنا عم نشوف يمكن الفكره العامه
او المود العامله هذه الجانيريشن بيتوقعه
اكثر ان يكونوا عم يستاهلوا على الاسس
الفاخره بسبب بتلاحظ السوشيال ميديا وكلها
الامور بتخلي الناس اللي بيهمك
طيب
ماسك على تويتر
وبين تسلا هذا الشيء عندنا انخفاض ثروت
ماسك الى اقل من 200 مليار دولار لو انت
تحدث عن توجههم المستثمرين
يعني اللعنه خصوصي انه الماسك تقريبا صار
هو الوجه العلامه التجاريه وكل حديث بيحكي
فيها عم باثر فعلا على همم الاسواق في
الوقت الحالي اذا عم نحكي عن تسله او توجه
الوستثمرن عم نشوف بالفعل تراجع تخوف عن
بلج نحكي انه هل حان الوقت انه نكون عم
نشوف مدير تنفيذي لشركه تسلا غير لهن مازر
طبيعه الحال هذا الشام باثر على الاسود
ولكن يعني الى الماسكوا الى الماسك من
وراء هل يمكن البلبل اللي بيعملها خلها
كمان اسهم بس لا ترتفع باكثر من 2000
بالميه منذ طرح الاسهم الى اليوم
في العام المقبل سنرى يمكن تراجع فيك
طاعتك من الوجع في معنويات المسافرين في
قطاع التكنولوجيا في حال استمرار تراجع
انه الاقتصاد طيب فرح عندما نتحدث عن قول
اغنى رجل في العالم ماذا يعني ذلك على كل
الاصعده كيف وصل لكي يحصل على هذا اللقب
يعني طبيعه الحال بدنا نشوف الشركات اللي
بيملكه همم سعر السهم اللي يملكه كمان قد
ايه بيملكه من قيمه الشركه همم او نسبه من
هذه الشركه فكل هذه الامور طبيعه الحال
الا ان معلنه خصوصا احنا عم نحكي عن شركات
مدرجه في الاسواق ففينا نكون عم نعرف قديش
كل يمكنر او همم مالك لهدول الاسهم بيملوا
بالفعل لانه هاي شركه مطروحه في الاصوات
فعندنا بياناتها موجوده للمستفيدين تكون
عم بتراقبهم شو رايك فينا نكون عم نعرف
قديش قيمه فعلا
جزيلا كنت معنا في الاستديو فرح مراد شكرا
فرح